Ultimate Spider-Man vs ultimate venom
this fight is amazing so what this does
is again this takes place in the
Ultimate Universe and we'll flesh out a
little bit more of that as we go through
this video but it initially opens up
basically in the aftermath of the
breakup between Peter Parker and Mary
Jane Watson now one of the things that
kind of went on in the ultimate universe
that we didn't necessarily need to cover
is exactly the kind of stuff that you
expect just from being casually aware of
the Spider-Man Mythos Peter gets his
powers and then his life is kind of
chaotic as he tries to deal with like
school and life and having abilities and
so on and so forth and so all this chaos
has really just kind of piled up the
breakup between him and Mary Jane Watson
is just the most recent thing to happen
but this has kind of sent him on a bit
of an existential crisis to the point
that he actually starts looking through
old boxes of things that belong to his
parents now something to understand
about Spider-Man in The Ultimate
Universe is that the role of his parents
is much bigger than it is in the main
Marvel Universe granted they're still
dead but the legacy of the things that
they've done lives on specifically with
regards to project Venom now we'll talk
about that here in a minute but one of
the things that had gone on here is that
as Peter Parker's going through and
looking at these videos he remembers a
friendship that he had with a kid named
Eddie Brock now one of the things about
this is that when it came to project
Venom that both Eddie Brock's father and
Peter Parker's Father Richard Parker had
worked on the project together and so
while Peter's kind of learning about all
this stuff what he does is he basically
reforms a connection with Eddie by
hitting him up and saying hey let's sit
down and talk because Eddie remembers
who Peter is he's actually a little bit
older he goes to college so as the two
of them reconnect and the two of them
start talking what Eddie does is he
tells Peter that he wants to show him
something why they do relive some
childhood memories and things that they
recall from when they were younger and
hung out all the time but Eddie Brock
ultimately leads Peter Parker to the lab
of Dr Kirk Connors now of course for
those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with Kirk Connors he's the lizard in the
Ultimate Universe it's the same way
right a desire to cure himself leads to
him basically taking a kind of substance
that turns them into like a giant
reptilian monster and like that's
basically it but when Eddie Brock brings
Peter to the lab he shows him this
Beaker with this black substance inside
and that's when he reveals the nature of
the Venom symbiote now this is a massive
difference in the Ultimate Universe
versus Marvel Comics in the main Marvel
Universe and in more recent years it's
been established that the Symbiotes are
literally created by this kind of God
and that he did it for the purpose of
effectively taking over the universe
ultimately he was defeated by a
combination of the celestials and his
own symbiotes and the rest of the
history unfolds from there right that
God's name was null the Symbiote God and
the Ultimate Universe totally different
the basis behind the Venom symbiote is
that it's one part tied into Captain
America and then one part engineered for
the purpose of curing cancer and the
reason why I say this is that when it
comes to Captain America in the Ultimate
Universe he's not the first person to
get the super soldier serum it was
actually Nick Fury Nick Fury got it
first then Captain America got its
second and so there's always been this
kind of mad dash by different
governments around the world to create
their own super soldiers a good example
of this is Wolverine we'll talk about
his significance here in a minute
because everybody thinks Spider-Man's a
mute but the thing about this is that
the nature of the Venom symbiote suit is
that it was designed to basically cure
cancer it was designed to cure different
illnesses that Humanity's been subjected
to over the course of its existence but
it never really got past stage two now
the way this worked is that Eddie Brock
senior and Richard Parker had developed
it and then ultimately ended up going to
Trask Industries right a company that
effectively took their experiment away
for the attempt of using it to create
new super soldiers in an attempt to kind
of rebuild a new Captain America and so
Richard Parker and Eddie Brock senior
went back to the drawing board and
created their own variation but they
stopped at stage two we don't fully know
why we will find out but they ultimately
stopped there and they never really got
any further than that and in fact what
ended up going on is they found
themselves in the midst of like this big
legal battle with Trask Industries
trying to reclaim the rights to the very
experiment that they had created but for
Eddie Brock this suit or this kind of
substance is the last living memory that
he has of his father but Peter Parker
who's more Curious than anything else
ultimately ends up leaving alongside
Eddie when this is shown to him but this
all kind of kicks off because as Peter
starts going through these old documents
of his father and the kind of things
they discuss he becomes more and more
curious about this thing this substance
that can be used to cure ailments in the
world and it seems like an inherently
good thing it seems like the benefit of
this suit far outweighs any potential
disadvantages that it may have and so
Peter Parker decides okay let's grab
this thing so he ends up going back to
Kurt Connor's lab he grabs the Venom
symbiote and then he puts it on now the
funny thing about this is this is very
reminiscent of the old Secret Wars cover
back in secret Wars 1984 where Peter
Parker got the Symbiote for the very
first time this whole circumstance is
almost identical to that because it's
kind of a Hallmark of Spider-Man's
character when the Symbiote initially
goes on to him unlike the old secret War
story where it's just like wow this is
kind of cool and crazy there's a whole
great big huge process where Peter's
overtaken by it he's horrified he's
trying to like escape from it because he
has no idea what's going on but it just
overtakes them entirely then it bonds to
him and then he becomes the Sleek Peter
Parker Spider-Man with the Venom
symbiote that we all know and love and
so following that he actually grabs the
suit and goes out into the world now
this is where things really start to go
sideways because in the mind of Peter
this suit grants him enhanced strength
and durability far beyond what he
already has and in fact in the middle of
a hostage situation where the ransom
that's about to go wrong Peter Parker
ends up jumping onto the car and then
ripping the entirety of the roof off and
then immediately going after these guys
now one of them opens fire on Peter it
hits him right in the Symbiote and the
Symbiote automatically heals this is
mind-blowing to Spider-Man because under
any normal circumstance if he was shot
it would basically kill him but he's not
impervious he's not indestructible to
any kind of damage a well-placed bullet
from Spider-Man's done with all his
living so one of the things that's
really astonishing here is that in a lot
of ways the Symbiote makes him basically
indestructible within a certain amount
of damage right you fire a nuke at him
Nothing's Gonna Save him so it's just
one of those things
one of those fun tidbits but something
that I want you to notice here that as
he's engaging in these different actions
against criminals he's becoming more and
more Reckless he's becoming more and
more extreme now for those of you guys
who are familiar with Toby Maguire
Spider-Man and emo Spider-Man when he
got the Venom symbiote it seems very
similar to this the reason why is
because those stories were based off
this story so that's why they seem very
similar but the thing here is that Peter
really just kind of relishes in this
suit right these Newfound abilities and
how capable he is and all the crazy
stuff that he can do and so he kind of
ignores the increasing level of
recklessness and even lack of concern
that he has for the livelihood of the
very villains that he's fighting because
normally Peter fights against them but
he doesn't really try to kill them and
if there's going to be collateral damage
he tries to minimize him but all of it
comes to a head when this guy Robs a
laundromat opens fire in the place ends
up shooting one of the people and then
takes off Peter Parker eventually
catches up to him only to realize this
is the guy that killed his Uncle Ben
that was kind of a mystery that had
never really been solved evolved up
until the Venom story we didn't really
know exactly anything about the guy who
had killed Uncle Ben or if Peter would
ever catch him but he finally does and
with the Venom symbiote he almost kills
him and this is when Peter starts to
realize he's losing control that the
Venom symbiote is dangerous that it
seems to almost have a mind of its own
and he can't quite control it now this
is very reminiscent of the main Marvel
Universe where Peter Parker somewhat
encountered the same thing one of the
big differences in the main Marvel
Universe when it came to Venom is the
Venom symbiote would actually go out and
do its own thing while Peter Parker was
asleep so Peter would have no idea
what's going on when the Venom symbiot's
going out and doing stuff it was only
when Peter started picking up on small
clues that he went to go see Reed
Richards of the Fantastic Four and read
said that's a living symbiote you need
to get rid of that right so again big
differences between the main Marvel
Universe and the Ultimate Universe but
this is where things get really wonky
here because once Peter realizes that
the symbiote's taking over him he tries
to get rid of it he doesn't initially
know how and in fact he can't readily
just remove it it's not until he's
stumbling and fumbling along that he
falls into some Electric lines and the
electricity is enough to blow the
Symbiote off of him and basically send
it running and so this allows Peter to
effectively recuperate him and then put
it back in the beaker and try to take it
back to the uh to the laboratory while
all that's going on Eddie Brock is
watching the news where you have like
this broadcast of Spider-Man running
around in a black suit putting two and
two together his thought is Peter
Parker's taking the suit like Peter took
that symbiote suit and he's out running
around with it when Eddie Brock gets
back to the laboratory he finds Peter
trying to sneak this back in and this is
when everything comes to a head up until
this point Eddie Brock didn't really
understand everything going on with
Peter Parker his powers the fact that he
was Spider-Man and even now he still
kind of doesn't it's quite literally a
movie scene Eddie Brock walks in he sees
Peter Parker he looks up and the
skylights open there's footprints that
run down to the ground and Peter
Parker's feet are dirty and it's like
okay so somehow or another you came
through the Skylight crawled in here and
you're dropping this off what in the
world is going on here and there's an
instance when Eddie Brock goes to grab
here and Peter lifts Eddie up with one
hand and that's when it Dawns on Eddie
Brock Peter Parker's Spider-Man and now
the other thing that goes on here is he
actually refers to Peter Parker as a
mutant now here's the reason why that's
the case one of the another really big
difference between the Ultimate Universe
and Marvel Comics and the main Marvel
universe is that in the main Marvel
Universe mutants are just people with an
x-gene and they activate under any
number of circumstances and they gain
powers and like that's it in the
Ultimate Universe mutants are so
publicly hated that anybody who has a
power is assumed to be a mutant because
nobody understands the definitive origin
that they have cycling back to that
point that we made about Wolverine
earlier Wolverine is the reason why that
after there was an attempt to bond the
super soldier serum to Captain America
it was also bonded to Wolverine but what
had happened is that during that point
in time the weapons plus project out in
Canada realized that Wolverine had a
healing Factor when they activated a
gene that they never encountered before
once they realized that was a gene that
granted Powers eventually the activation
process was synthesized it was spread
across the world and that's where you
get mutants from in the Ultimate
Universe so it all goes back to
Wolverine right it all goes back to him
but the fact is that because of actions
of guys like Magneto and the ultimate
X-Men Comics different things like that
specifically once you get to ultimatum
mutants are just reviled across the
world so it's not something that you
readily tell people if you're a mutant
in the Ultimate Universe you keep that
to yourself
that's why Peter Silva humanly rejects
the fact that he's a mutant because he
doesn't want anybody to actually think
that he is but he even goes so far as to
reveal to Eddie Brock yes I am
Spider-Man and I'm telling you I'm
Spider-Man because I need you to trust
me without a shadow of a doubt I put
this symbiote on I understand what it
means to wear this thing it's almost got
a mind of its own it's why our fathers
couldn't get past stage two it was too
dangerous that it couldn't be bonded to
anybody because it ultimately corrupted
them and just turned them into a killing
machine there was nothing that could be
done it's why Trask Industries and the
government wanted it because they could
slap it onto Marines or guys from the
Army and send them out into some Warfare
and just have the massacre and Slaughter
everybody if this thing cannot exist it
has to be destroyed and where Eddie
Brock doesn't want to get rid of it due
to the fact that it's like the last
living thing that links him to his
father in the end Peter asks him do you
trust that I'm telling you the truth do
you trust this thing is truly dangerous
when I tell you that it's dangerous and
the response of Eddie is yes and so
Peter says I'm going to take this and
I'm going to destroy it I'm going to get
rid of it now what's so interesting
about this is that when Peter leaves the
response of Eddie is I need a second to
digest everything that's going on but we
end up learning here that is kind of a
controlled experiment now Marvel's very
ambiguous about this we don't know if
Eddie Brock leaked information about the
Symbiote to Peter Parker because he
wanted Peter to put it on and he wanted
to see what would happen if Peter did
right like you take it first I'll see if
you die and if you don't then I'll try
it if it's that kind of a thing or if
Eddie was truly telling Peter about this
because they share history together and
their fathers worked on the experiment
and that was it but regardless of of
what the motivation is Eddie Brock ends
up grabbing a portion of the Symbiote
for himself kind of a backup sample and
then bonds to it and it just begins to
overtake him exactly the way that you
would expect and so what goes on here is
that when a janitor enters in the next
morning Eddie Brock immediately kills
him because one of those similarities
between the Venom symbiote and the main
Marvel Universe and the Ultimate
Universe was the initial desire to
consume people so it's really wild and
really cool to see that happen this guy
basically gets eaten so I feel bad for
this poor sat because the guy was doing
his job and then suddenly he gets eaten
by a giant black amorphous blob so the
thing here is that once Eddie emerges
and almost seems to kind of gain control
of the Venom symbiote then he just sort
of goes forward from there as the Venom
that we all know and love a couple of
security guards show up and Venom helps
these guys finish with all their living
and so once it tracks Spider-Man down to
Midtown high school that Peter Parker
immediately responds and the response of
Eddie Brock is you shouldn't have lied
to me and that's one of the things that
Peter begins to pick up on when it comes
to the Venom symbiote that sure to a
degree it is a dangerous organism that's
almost impossible to control but when it
has a host it picks up on the memories
and the emotions of that host because
the feelings of Eddie Brock were
feelings of betrayal because Peter
Parker was told the secret and then went
and donned the suit because of the fact
that Peter wanted to destroy it which
angered Eddie because it was the last
thing that connected him to his dad what
the Venom symbiote feels is anger and
betrayal so that's why there's so much
hatred towards Peter it's very
reminiscent of the main Marvel Universe
where Eddie Brock became venom out there
because Peter Parker basically cost
Eddie his job and so all that anger that
Eddie Brock had merged with the anger
the Symbiote held over Peter getting rid
of it and then it basically became
Spider-Man's really most iconic enemy at
that point in time and I would still
argue that Venom is probably the most
popular animated Spider-Man has but the
bigger Point going on here is that a
massive fight breaks out between the two
and Peter starts to realize how
overwhelmed he is because Peter facing
off against someone like Venom it's
basically Peter facing off against
himself without any kind of blocks which
is to say No Reservations just a full-on
maddening desire to kill type of villain
so it just takes Peter for one heck of a
wild ride it takes him on the Pain Train
man I mean it's just like throwing them
through buildings right just absolutely
trying to tear him apart piece by piece
Peter starts to realize it's not really
Eddie Brock that's in control here it's
the Venom symbiote feeding on the
emotions of Eddie Brock and then acting
accordingly but it doesn't make it any
less dangerous and there's more than a
few times where Peter Parker almost gets
killed what he realizes here is that he
has to basically incapacitate Eddie he's
got to incapacitate the Venom Symbian
and then figure out a way to win right
just kind of like escape with his life
and so as the fight gets more and more
chaotic spreading throughout the town
smashing into cars breaking into
buildings right just laying waste to
huge sections of Queens right just
demolishing huge sections of this area
that initially the Venom Soviet goes to
absorb Spider-Man and it almost does it
almost completely absorbs Spider-Man
like to the point where he would
basically be a part of it and he would
effectively be gone Peter's able to make
his Escape but a momentary distraction
comes by way of cops who open fire and
then the Venom symbiote ends up
stumbling into a live electrical wire it
gets electrocuted and then that's
seemingly the end of it that in a moment
it basically looks like Eddie Brock is
dead and so following that and without a
mask to hide his identity the cops
chasing after him trying to figure out
what's going on Peter just flees for his
life and he goes to the only person that
he possibly can go to he goes to Nick
Fury now the reason for this is because
in the Ultimate Universe Samuel Jackson
Nick Fury that's actually where it
originally started if I recall correctly
Samuel Jackson was gonna Sue Marvel for
using his likeness without his
permission and the agreement that was
struck is that Samuel Jackson would be
allowed to play Nick Fury in the MCU how
much of that is true I don't entirely
know it may just be one of those myths
of the mcu's history I have no clue but
the important thing is that when Nick
Fury came on is basically the director
of Shield that he's the one that really
just leads this superhero Community
instead of the Avengers you have the
ultimates so you have Spider-Man who was
eventually brought in by Nick Fury once
Nick Fury realized it was better to have
Spider-Man operating as an ally and a
superhero that he could train as opposed
to just a kid out there doing stuff now
ultimately it just turned into a
situation where he was just a kid out
there doing stuff but still right Nick
Fury is the guy that Peter parking can
go to whenever he has problems and when
he sits down and talks to Nick Fury what
he finds is Fury is far less
understanding than he would initially
expect the fury goes so far as to say
look man like there's no rules here when
it comes to this right there's no
governing Force there's no giant you
know white board out there in The Ether
that has a list of guidelines that
you're supposed to follow all you ever
do is the best you can and sometimes you
screw up and there's collateral damage
and the only thing you can do is try to
clean things up at the moment right now
Shield is actually dealing with the
Calamity in the aftermath of everything
that happened in Queens in the fight
between Peter Parker and Vin right so
they're cleaning all that stuff up but
the response of Nick is like did you
kill him and the answer from Peter is
I'm not entirely sure and Nick Fury says
first rule of being a superhero if you
don't see a corpse assume they're still
alive go fix this mess get it cleaned up
and if I ever catch you following me
around like this again and you try to
meet with me without making an
appointment I will shoot you so
understand man Nick Fury is not your
friend in the Ultimate Universe
right I mean he's the guy you want on
your side don't get me wrong but he's
not like a jovial kind person he's a
dick like he's just really kind of a
crappy guy and so following that Peter
ends up going back to the lab of Kurt
Connors only to find that Kirk Connors
is there the hope is that he could catch
Eddie Brock there right or he could find
something that would indicate where
Eddie Brock has gone to or some way to
permanently destroy any other future
samples that may exist of the Venom
symbiance so that when the time comes
when he encounters Eddie again it's just
a one-on-one Showdown Peter can win the
Symbiote will be destroyed Eddie Brock
can be saved roll credits what he ends
up finding here is Dr Kirk Connors now
again Peter Parker and Kirk Connors have
history that Kirk Connor's history in
the Ultimate Universe is very similar to
the main Marvel Universe we don't
exactly know how it was that he lost his
arm but he basically injected himself
with a serum using the regenerative
capabilities of a reptile in an attempt
to regrow his arm and then he became the
lizard but by Peter Parker facing off
against him realizing it was Kurt
Connors and then basically helping him
to return to a state of normalcy that
this was really really just kind of the
two of them having an olive branch so
even where Peter tells Kirk Connors hey
man like yeah I'm Spider-Man right which
Kirk Connors had more or less already
figured out that Kirk Connors even go so
far as to tell him there's no more
samples left there's nothing here man
like I came back here to check on my lap
any samples any documents the whole nine
yards the place has been cleaned out
there's nothing that remains here
presumably it was Eddie Brock who did it
that it was Eddie Brock that came in
emptied the place so there's no
conceivable way to destroy any evidence
here assuming that Eddie Brock hasn't
done it already and there's no other
sample so Peter Parker to eliminate so
there's nothing he can do here right and
so it's one of these things where he
just kind of gets frustrated right he
gets frustrated the entirety of the
situation and more so than that Kirk
Connors has a very cynical perspective
here right he tells Peter Parker like
I'm sorry about what's going on the
creation of this suit and everything
with your dad and when when Peter Parker
asks what do you mean the response of
Kirk Connors is your father was a genius
and an admirable man of science but now
looking at the end result of his
experiments seeing the doors they open
and where they are now it looks like he
might have been the architect the pie
near of this horrible decade of genetic
nightmares and so one of the things
that's kind of put forward here by Kirk
Connors albeit not entirely true that
the rise of mutants the wars that take
place among mutants right like all these
different skirmishes that lay waste to
different cities and towns the deaths of
people who were caught in the middle as
collateral damage that maybe it was all
because of Richard Parker and it was all
because of Peter Parker's dad and maybe
Edward Brock or something like that no
one knows for sure because no one really
has any answers no one really knows that
it all started with Wolverine and the
attempt to bond a super soldier serum to
his body it's one of the best kept
secrets in the entirety of the Ultimate
Universe so in a search for answers
people just kind of hypothesize where
they can when they can granted Kirk
Connors is drunk and he's spouting off
at the mouth but it offends Peter Parker
nonetheless because the reality here is
that given the dangerous nature of the
Symbiote there's no reason to believe
that the experiments of Richard and
Edward Brock senior could have very well
contributed to everything else that's
going on and so where Peter Parker takes
off to kind of try to Center himself
while he's on a rooftop he thinks he
sees Eddie bro out of the corner of his
eye but when he runs over there Eddie
Brock's nowhere to be found and so in
essence Peter's just kind of left there
alone with the guilt of his own actions
the possibility of the fact that his
father may have contributed to most of
society's problems knowing full wealth
Venoms out there God only knows what
he's going to do but he's certainly
going to keep on killing people and it's
all Peter Parker's fault with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end because don't worry venom does
return
and I will catch you all later peace